(upbeat music)
- At Aviation High School,
we take all your regular
academic classes, English,
social studies, physical education.
But then also we have ground operations,
carburative magnetos,
jet engines.
This airplane behind me
is my classroom everyday.
I'm Martin Sienczuk,
and I'm a student at Aviation High School.
And I currently go to
class at JFK Airport.
- Aviation High School is a
public New York City high school.
Students at Aviation High School
spend 4 to 5 years working
on repairing airplanes.
And in the process they get their
licensing to work in the industry
from the Federal Aviation Administration.
We have a hangar on site
in our main building,
where we have 17 aircraft.
We've been teaching students for 81 years
to work in the aviation industry.
We're very proud to be the school
that certifies the most
mechanics in the country.
- The responsibility of an
aircraft mechanic is huge.
I have to ensure that every
single bolt, every single screw,
every single piece of wire
is safely secured on that aircraft.
Prevent anything from happening
while it's in the air.
When we sign off any part,
it's basically our signature
that's allowing the airplane
to get into the sky.
And our signature is worth gold.
We are letting over 100
people on the ground
get into the sky and get
to their destination.
I like working with my hands,
I like getting out in the world.
I love seeing the work that
I put in fly in the air.